Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Une tomate a besoin de deux ingrédients
pour pouvoir pousser :
de la chaleur et de l’eau.
Quand cette tomate pousse en Espagne,
elle n’a pas de mal à trouver sa chaleur
avec ces plaines gorgées de soleil.
Pour l’eau, c’est tout de suite
un peu plus compliqué.
Entourée de rivières à sec, il faut aller
chercher plus profond, encore plus loin,
pour réussir à trouver de l’eau,
quitte à surexploiter les nappes
au-delà de leur capacité.
Mais il arrive parfois que
cette tomate ait aussi besoin de vent.
Vous allez me dire : « Quelle relation
entre une tomate et le vent ? »
Eh bien, lorsque cette tomate pousse
dans d’immenses serres aux Pays-Bas,
elle se réchauffe
grâce aux éoliennes offshore.
Or, cette année, en mer du Nord,
le vent a faibli.
Donc, pour réchauffer notre tomate,
ce n’est pas grave,
on va se reporter sur le gaz naturel.
On va le chercher plus loin,
beaucoup plus loin,
à l’autre bout des gazoducs européens,
en Russie ou encore au Qatar.
Mais cette année, à 7500 kilomètres de là,
la Chine vient de vivre
une de ses pires sécheresses.
Les fleuves ont diminué de près de 80%,
empêchant l’utilisation
des barrages hydro-électriques.
Alors, pour pouvoir trouver cette énergie,
la Chine se reporte sur le charbon.
Sauf que le charbon a aussi besoin
de beaucoup, beaucoup d'eau.
Alors ce n’est pas grave,
on a une solution facile.
On va importer massivement
du charbon et du gaz naturel.
Notre tomate hollandaise se retrouve
alors en concurrence
avec la production mondiale chinoise.
Comment dire ?
Nous risquons de ne pas beaucoup
manger de gaspacho cet été.
Cette tomate nous raconte
surtout une histoire.
L'histoire de notre dépendance cachée.
Celle que l'on ne veut pas voir.
Derrière tous nos modes de vie, tout ce
que l’on consomme, se cache de l’énergie.
Mais derrière l’énergie
se cache surtout de l’eau.
Les barrages hydro-électriques
n’ont plus de raison d’être sans eau.
Imaginez 800 000 barrages à travers le
monde à sec, qui ne serviraient à rien.
Les centrales nucléaires ont besoin
d’eau froide en continu
pour fournir la vapeur qui permet
de faire tourner les turbines.
Le pétrole a notamment besoin d’eau
en l’injectant pour permettre
justement son extraction.
Le charbon, lui aussi, a besoin
de beaucoup d’eau dans d’immenses
cuves pour permettre de l’extraire.
Tenez, juste aux États-Unis,
c’est entre 250 et 1000
millions de litres d’eau par jour
qui sont nécessaires
pour extraire le charbon.
Alors,
lorsque cette ressource vient
à manquer, comment fait-on ?
L’éolien et le solaire ont peut-être
de beaux jours devant eux.
Un autre domaine où on a notamment
besoin d’énormément d’eau,
c’est notre consommation, notre assiette.
Une kilocalorie, c’est un litre d’eau.
Il nous en faut à peu près 3000 pour
pouvoir nous nourrir toute la journée.
Donc 3000 litres d'eau par jour.
Si vous rajoutez à cela les produits
pour pouvoir transformer notre nourriture,
la packager,
à ce moment-là, nous passons à 5000,
à 7000 litres d’eau utilisés par jour.
Enfin, si on rajoute tous nos modes
de vie, puisque tout a besoin d’eau -
nos T-shirts, nos voitures,
nos moyens de transport -
là, on consomme entre 8000
et 10 000 litres d’eau par jour.
Cette eau que nous consommons,
c’est de l’eau qui vient d’ailleurs.
On appelle ça de l'eau virtuelle.
En fait, le problème de l’eau,
c’est qu’elle a trop de qualités.
Si c’était un humain,
on la qualifierait de haut potentiel.
Et c’est bien connu, quelque chose
ou quelqu’un qui a trop de qualités,
on a tendance à beaucoup,
beaucoup l’utiliser, voire l’exploiter.
C’est vrai que nous passons nos neuf
premiers mois dans une poche d’eau
et lorsque nous en ressortons,
nous sommes encore
majoritairement faits d’eau.
Rien que nos cerveaux sont composés
à 76% de molécules d'eau.
Mais alors, va-t-on réellement
manquer d’eau ?
Vous allez me dire : « En France,
avec nos 500 milliards de mètres cubes
d’eau qui tombent chaque année,
on ne craint absolument rien. »
Sauf que, en réalité,
c’est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
Déjà, 65 % repartent
immédiatement dans l’atmosphère.
Ensuite, 26% ruissellent
dans nos rivières et nos fleuves
et seulement 9 % réussissent
à s’infiltrer dans les sols.
Enfin, 9%, c’est quand les sols n’ont
pas subi d’agriculture intensive
ou ne sont pas urbanisés.
Mais certains vous disent :
« Mais ne vous inquiétez pas,
on peut pomper l’eau l’hiver,
on en a trop, sinon on la perd. »
Sauf que la planète est en train
de nous raconter une nouvelle histoire.
La sécheresse.
Elle est en train de pointer le bout
de son nez sur les cinq continents,
elle n’épargne personne.
Elle s'aggrave d'année en année et
s'accentue à travers chaque canicule.
En France, sur ces quatre
dernières années,
nous venons de vivre quatre années
consécutives de sécheresse historique.
Et lorsque nous ne sommes pas
touchés de plein fouet,
c'est tout autour de nous que ça brûle.
La Grèce, l'Algérie ou encore l'Espagne.
Si on n’a plus d’eau, on pense
tout de suite à notre assiette.
Comment allons-nous faire ?
Eh bien, c’est très simple,
il suffit d’aller au supermarché.
À partir du moment où nous consommons
de l’eau qui a été produite ailleurs,
finalement, cela ne nous
impacte pas directement.
D’ailleurs, de nombreux pays
sont absolument incapables
de fournir de l’alimentation
pour leur propre population
à partir de leurs réserves.
Le supermarché, c’est de l’eau
que nous consommons ailleurs,
de l’eau qui est produite loin.
Mais lorsqu’il n’y a plus d’eau ailleurs ?
Tenez, par exemple, la Californie,
premier État exportateur agricole.
Elle, cette année, vient de vivre sa pire
sécheresse depuis 1200 ans :
plus une goutte d’eau qui ne coule
de la Sierra Nevada
en direction des terres
autrefois irriguées massivement.
Mais alors, que faire ?
Il y a peut-être
une solution assez rapide :
il suffit simplement d’aller
chercher de l’eau au Canada
et de la faire descendre
le long de la côte Ouest.
Sauf que le Canada vient
notamment de vivre
une de ses pires sécheresses
depuis le printemps.
Des dômes de chaleur dévastateurs.
Cette ville de Lytton qui a été dévastée
en l’espace de quelques heures.
Mais finalement, ça signifie quoi
pour nous, la Californie ?
Ce sont nos oranges, nos amandes.
C’est aussi une grande partie
de l’assiette de l’Américain moyen
qui, faute d’approvisionnement, va aller
chercher sur le marché international
ses denrées alimentaires
aux mêmes endroits que nous.
D'autres sécheresses ont des répercussions
encore bien plus visibles.
Prenez Taïwan.
Ça correspond aux 2/3 de la production
mondiale de puces électroniques.
Or, Taïwan n’a pas vécu
de typhons cette année
et vit lui aussi une des sécheresses
les plus extrêmes qu’il ait connues.
Pour produire des puces électroniques,
il faut aussi de l’eau, beaucoup d’eau.
Le premier industriel de l’île consomme,
à lui tout seul, sur trois usines,
150 000 tonnes d’eau par jour.
Nous risquons de ne pas pouvoir nous
acheter de console de jeux vidéo,
ni le dernier SUV flambant neuf
ou encore de smartphones.
Dans la sécheresse qui se déroule
actuellement avec la Chine,
c’est une tout autre histoire
qui se raconte,
potentiellement
une rupture d’approvisionnement
de tout le made in China.
Là, c’est encore un peu plus compliqué.
On risque de ne plus avoir
grand-chose à acheter.
Et pourtant, en réalité,
depuis des millions d’années,
nous avons toujours eu
la même quantité d’eau sur Terre.
Nous en perdons un peu
en haute atmosphère.
Nous en regagnons grâce aux comètes.
Nous en perdons un peu
dans les zones de subduction
et on en regagne encore
dans les dorsales océaniques.
En gros, on a toujours autant d'eau.
Mais alors, finalement,
quel est le problème ?
D’accord, elle est mal répartie,
mais il y a bien des géants de l’eau.
Prenez le Brésil.
Lui, 65% de son électricité sont produits
par ses barrages hydro-électriques.
Sauf que le Brésil vient de vivre
sa pire sécheresse depuis 91 ans.
Mais alors où va cette eau,
l’eau réellement disponible pour l’homme ?
L’eau douce,
ce ne sont pas les 96,6% d’eau
que l’on retrouve
dans nos océans et nos mers.
À quoi correspond cette eau ?
Eh bien, l'eau de nos rivières
et de nos fleuves,
c’est 0,00012%
de l'eau planétaire.
Certains ont bien tenté
d’aller récupérer de l’eau
en faisant venir des icebergs
dans les années 70,
mais ils se sont vite arrêtés,
vu le coût de transport.
Il reste bien encore 1 % d’eau
dans nos nappes souterraines.
Seulement,
à force de surexploiter ces nappes
au-delà de leur capacité,
de toujours plus prélever
dans nos rivières et dans nos fleuves.
En réalité, cette eau, elle finit où ?
Elle finit dans les océans
et dans l’atmosphère.
Dans les océans, elle contribue largement
à surélever le niveau marin.
Dans l’atmosphère,
l’eau fait ce qu’elle sait
faire de mieux :
être un gaz à effet de serre.
Vous allez me dire : « Mais rien à voir !
C’est le dioxyde de carbone
le principal gaz à effet de serre. »
C’est celui-là, effectivement,
dont on nous parle tout le temps,
mais en réalité , la vapeur d’eau,
c’est 95% des gaz à effet de serre.
Le dioxyde de carbone, c’est juste 4,1%.
Effectivement,
la différence entre les deux,
c’est que le CO2 va rester
dans l’atmosphère
alors que l’eau, elle, à un moment
donné, elle va se condenser
et elle va se transformer en pluie.
Mais plus vous avez
une température élevée,
plus vous allez avoir de l’eau
qui va s’évaporer,
plus vous allez avoir cet effet de serre
qui va à nouveau réchauffer,
plus vous aurez encore de l’évaporation.
Et dans ce cycle sans fin,
ce qui se produit,
c’est qu’à un moment donné,
toute cette vapeur d’eau qui se condense
finit par précipiter sous la forme
de pluies diluviennes dévastatrices.
Alors...
comment réussir à recréer
cet équilibre du cycle de l’eau ?
Eh bien, en reconstruisant,
boucle après boucle, à petite échelle,
ce cycle de l’eau.
En reforestant,
en donnant une valeur au sol,
en restaurant les zones humides.
À partir de ce moment-là,
vous réussissez à avoir une action
qui, en réalité, est colossale.
Rien qu’en diminuant la viande
dans notre assiette,
nous contribuons à faire en sorte
que la production de céréales
serve pour les populations,
alors qu’aujourd’hui 70%
des céréales mondiales
sont fabriquées pour le bétail,
sans compter les consommations d’eau
ou encore les émissions de méthane.
Alors, seulement, nous pourrons
reconstruire pas à pas notre résilience.
À sept ans,
j’ai déménagé de ma banlieue parisienne
pour atterrir dans une petite vallée
paisible dans les Pyrénées-Orientales.
Moi qui étais plutôt habituée
à voir décoller
les avions et les dirigeables du Bourget,
je me suis retrouvée à basculer
dans un tout nouvel univers
que je ne connaissais absolument pas,
étant plutôt éloignée de la Seine
et de tout cours d’eau.
Là, j’ai débarqué au milieu
des sources chaudes,
des gorges, des petites rivières
et notamment un petit fleuve, le Tech.
Lors de mes balades dominicales,
je me suis un jour trouvée
face à une photo en noir et blanc.
Sur cette photo,
j’y voyais le même pont devant moi,
mais complètement déchiqueté,
des murs et des immeubles
complètement ravagés.
Je me suis dit qu’un jour
je chercherais à comprendre
ce qui avait pu se passer
dans cette petite vallée paisible.
Je suis alors devenue hydrologue.
Les sciences de l'eau.
Des crues éclairs dévastatrices
aux sécheresses extrêmes,
en passant par la gestion
de la ressource en eau.
Je me suis mise à lire
les évolutions de ce territoire
et je me suis retrouvée finalement aux
premières loges de ces transformations
que l'on vit aujourd'hui sous nos yeux.
Ce cheminement m’a amenée
aux premières loges
de cette transformation qui est en train
de se jouer actuellement
avec ce changement climatique.
En réalité, derrière ces sécheresses,
ce sont tous nos modes de vie
qui sont en train de s’écrouler
les uns après les autres.
La nature nous ramène au centre,
à l'essentiel.
Respecter ces territoires.
Faire en sorte de protéger
nos nappes surexploitées et polluées,
nos rivières asséchées.
C'est nous derrière que nous protégeons.
Alors peut-être, le plus grand acte
militant que vous pouvez avoir
se trouve juste
au bout de votre fourchette.
Et, comme dirait Candide, qui a traversé
le monde à chercher son Eldorado :
« Un conseil : cultivez votre jardin. »
(Applaudissements)